let's let's talk about michael hastings
okay so we can we can you know this
this crazy stuff all right the first
thing you got to do
is hit the like button but normally
we're more uh enthusiastic about it but
we'll keep everything
you know fairly serious if you haven't
already please consider smashing the
like button it does help the channel
and subscribe if you haven't already and
you can follow all of us i'm on twitter
instagram parlor tim cast you can follow
at adam kriegler
in the same places and you can follow at
sourpatch lids l-y-d-s
there you go and uh yeah no but for real
yeah abs absolutely hit the like button
if you would be so kind takes only but a
second and share
share this video that really helps us
also i want to talk to you guys about
michael hastings
and the reason why is because
there are a lot of people in media who
want to who want to uh downplay
the epstein stuff it's a conspiracy
theory oh no it happened aren't our
prison systems just
so awful that proves it
no no no no sorry i don't i don't buy it
listen man
i'm not a conspiracy fan i can't tell
you who did what or why but i can tell
you an investigation needs to be done
beyond what they claim
period i don't think it's fair to say
that when it comes to cases like epstein
or
or otherwise there's a lot of
confidential and secret information
they're not going to tell you it's hard
to know what what to believe but
conspiracies
harm the actual quest for truth because
you have to make sure the evidence
guides you and you don't
leap forward and then work backwards and
that's the problem with in my opinion
with a lot of conspiracy theorists
is they'll see a story like you know
like epstein and be like i know who did
it and they'll choose their one
politician they don't like be it hillary
clinton or donald trump
and then try and work things back to
prove what they think
instead of starting somewhere and
following the evidence and going down
the path and then being like wow i can't
believe it it was neither
i'm not going to say any names i could
make a funny joke about some obscure
politician but considering the severity
of the story i won't
but i introduce you now to the story of
michael hastings
and uh i mean with with all due respect
to michael to his friends to his family
i i'm you know i'm i know it's probably
a sore subject for a lot of people this
man lost his life
i know uh many people who knew him were
good friends with him
and this was a crazy story back in 2013
that sent
chills down the spines of many
journalists
probably some of the last few
journalists who existed until they saw
this story
and then all of a sudden around the same
time
you know started happening journalists
started joining the pr field and
marketing
i'm not going to say that it's
completely due to this it does have to
do with the fact the industry was
collapsing
i'd be willing to bet though considering
some of the conversations i have
some people were like i'm gonna go
figure out how to sell tickets to a
movie theater
i'm gonna go work at buzzfeed and write
about brad pitt's junk
no that wasn't those people no no that
was never those people the people who
did that are the people who are like
go to journalism school and then can't
find a job so they go to buzzfeed and
write about brad pitt's junk right okay
i'm talking about people who actually
were doing infosec hacker community high
profile stuff
okay and then at some point decided
marketing was way
with a way better idea yeah let's sell
hot dogs time to learn a new people
use my my social skills and you know do
research
sell hot dogs i wonder why no it is fair
to say that i think for the most part
because the industry was collapsing
but you gotta look at this story so the
reason i highlight this
whenever someone tells you that it's a
conspiracy don't believe it
you can talk about this who killed
michael hastings from new york magazine
by benjamin wallace this is a mainstream
high-profile publication
asking who killed this man let me read
you the story
actually apparently i can't let me see
if i can it's booted me out
new york mag see if we can fix it
i think i got it i think i got it it's
probably gonna lock me out soon
sneaky they say at the end of his life
michael hastings like many of the
progressive journalists he counted among
his friends felt besieged by an
overreaching government
hastings was living in los angeles and
at a beverly hills theater in april
he took part in a panel discussion about
the documentary war on whistleblowers
free press
and the national security state
interviewed in may on the young turks a
talk show on current tv well it used to
be
hastings railed against the obama
administration which has clearly
declared war on the press
the only recourse he said was for the
press to respond we declare war on you
on may 31st he dashed off an urgent
tweet
first they came for manning then assange
then fox
then the ap drake and the other
whistleblowers
and nyt reporters too he attended
screenings of his friend jeremy scahill
from dirty wars
which uh screen of jeremy scales film
dirty wars
which seeks to expose the hidden truth
behind america's expanding covert wars
and when leaks about the nsa began
appearing in the guardian and edward
snowden oh they're just booted me out
again
oh for pizza wants me to spend five
dollars no let me let me let me go down
just to the uh i'll try and yeah
they say by the middle of june though
hastings then 33 become openly afraid
helicopter helicopters are a common
sight in hollywood hills but he had told
jordana thigpen a neighbor he'd become
close to
that there were more of them in the sky
than usual and he was certain they were
tracking him
on saturday the 15th he called matt
farwell the his writing partner
and said farwell might be interviewed by
the fbi
farwell was unsettled and said for okay
he was
being really cagey over the phone which
was odd very odd farwell says
on the 17th hastings emailed colleagues
at buzzfeed to warn them
that the feds are interviewing my close
friends and associates
he was onto a big story and needed to go
off the radar for a bit hope to see you
all soon
he was deeply i take back that buzzfeed
thing i guess i didn't realize he worked
for did i call that
yeah he was deep he was deeply agitated
says jankuge of the young turks
since hastings didn't want to say
anything more over email or the phone
farwell who lived in virginia set up a
lunch for him the following thursday
with a trusted friend the lunch never
happened at 4 20 am on tuesday june 18th
hastings silver mercedes c250 coupe
speeding south on highland avenue
crossed melrose jumped the median hit a
palm tree and exploded
the charred body of the driver was
identified by the la coroner as john doe
117 until fingerprints confirmed
that the deceased was michael hastings
sergeant joe biggs who met hastings in
08 when the reporter was on assignment
for gq
was embedded with his unit in
afghanistan hadn't spoken to his friend
in three months
but hastings had bcced him on the june
17 email to buzzfeed colleagues
i tried calling him when i got that
email big said because i felt so effing
scared
but it didn't seem like him they weren't
helpful at all i kept emailing back what
should we do i'm not a journalist i
don't know how to go about this stuff
they never responded to me biggs tried
contacting other media to let them know
about the ominous email
the only person who got back to him was
a local la reporter if that thing hadn't
been
if that thing didn't get released biggs
told me when i first called him two
weeks after hastings death people would
keep thinking it was an accident
they say hastings lived as he died i'm
not going to read into all this stuff
i'm going to jump over now to the
wikipedia that explains
much more simply i just wanted to read
you that story for one reason that was a
high-profile mainstream news source the
new york mag
asking the question who killed him this
is michael's michael hastings
uh wikipedia entry he was born in 1980
he was 33 when he died and they have a
section
called controversy over alleged foul
play
soon after hastings death questions were
raised about the crash that took his
life
former u.s national coordinator for
security infrastructure protection and
counterterrorism richard a clark
said that what is known about the crash
is consistent with a car cyber attack
he was quoted as saying there is reason
to believe that intelligence agencies
for major powers including the us
know how to remotely seize control of a
car so if there were a cyber attack on
hastings car
and i'm not saying there was i think
whoever did it would probably get away
with it
i don't know if this was before or after
i believe it was after
there was actually a couple of
journalists who display who demonstrated
overt legit car hack of select vehicles
wow i i most people don't know this but
you can remote control your average car
right now even if it doesn't have
automatic driving this blew my mind i
remember that
i think they had a demonstration at the
black at def con big hacker convention
in
la but they literally just took over the
computer of a car take your hands off
the wheel and they could steer it
remotely in the wheel turns
i didn't know you could do that
apparently that's like a normal thing
and so they they did a couple uh tests
where they're like driving on the
highway and they took over someone's car
remotely who had a journalist
for uh for wire that took over his car
while he was driving to demonstrate it
if these hackers these researchers
figured how to do this it was a very
clever workaround because there's like
very few connections between these
systems
what do you think state you know
intelligence agencies could pull off
they could they could make it happen
right let's read a little bit more seems
like it
the day before the crash hastings
indicated that he believed he was being
investigated by the fbi
in an email to colleagues that's what
they were referencing before which was
copied
uh to and released by hastings friend
amy army staff sergeant joe biggs
hastings said that he was onto a big
story that he needed to go off the radar
and the fbi might interview him
wikileaks announced that hastings had
also contacted jennifer robinson one of
its lawyers
a few hours prior to the crash and the
la weekly reported
that he was preparing new reports on the
cia at the time of his death
his widow elise jordan said his final
story was a profile of cia director john
brennan
john brennan oh i don't i don't know
much about
john brennan he uh john big name yes
he uh this article that i found says
that hastings work was a thorn in the
side of the government yeah
so i would say that's brennan that
sounds consistent well when it comes to
brennan
i'm not going to get too much into it
but ask the the obamagate researchers
the people tracking the trump spying
scandal obamacare stuff
about brennan too many names and i'm not
i can't i can't give i can't derail into
the whole obama gate stuff right now
but i'm pretty sure everyone in the chat
is going to light it up and be like
brennan just because you said it yep
just
that simple fact they're gonna be like
whoa
they're gonna look into it yeah man tim
for wars we're gonna get in trouble
they're gonna show up i'm being very
careful with what i'm saying
i don't mean on youtube if hastings was
a thorn in the side of the government
and now we're talking about all this
stuff yeah man i don't know man
i don't i'm not saying that the hastings
stuff has anything to do with the
epstein stuff not at all
i'm just saying like this is weird stuff
let me read a little bit more let me
read it more you said you said that you
you play it right in the middle and
you're you're you try to be a fence
sitter
you know and that's kind of how you
thread i don't try to be a friend sitter
try to be correct yeah okay that's
that's true but
you know once you push a narrative and
not that i push a narrative because i'm
i'm very much like you that where i want
to know all sides of the
the but i have made a decision on who
i'm going to vote for and i've talked
about it
multiple times you know and it's like i
they'll just ban you
they gotta get rid of you well i hope
that's the extent of it
if that's the exact same thing does
happen yeah that's probably it
the bigger the bigger thing i think
someone like you would have to worry
about for those for those that are
probably aren't familiar maybe just
tuning in adam
did this you know had this huge segment
where you're like you're announcing here
to support trump and you're like a
regular old urban
default liberal not super political yeah
the bigger risk i think is you know far
left lunatics
coming your page harassing you smearing
you lying about you
and trying to get you banned from the
internet so adam did this video where he
talked about voting for trump
and then facebook deleted it after
millions of views that's true like a
couple different times
and it became this big deal where people
were posting like yo where'd this video
go it's gone right
so then we did a new segment you know
that segment we did where we talked
about it 800
000 views now on youtube wow really yeah
and i'm glad we brought it back up
because they took it down
so i can only imagine we're not long for
the digital world i suppose we'll see
how we'll see what happens
but i'll let's i want to read a little
bit a little bit more here
just i'll just read the last part they
say the possibility of a conspiracy or
some sort of government involvement in
hastings death has been discounted by
members of his own family
who are with him around the time of his
death hastings widow elise jordan
has said she believes his death to be
just a really tragic accident
other members of his family have stated
that they were concerned at the time
that he was a danger to himself from his
erratic behavior
his older brother jonathan had just
flown to la attempting to organize
some sort of family intervention for
what he believed was a drug-induced
manic episode
a concern apparently echoed by others
close to him at the time
maybe i'll defer i'll defer completely
to the family on these kinds of issues
but i'd have to imagine if
i was working on a big story that was
going to profile on
the director of the cia yeah and i was
you know found something and i send an
email saying i got a huge story this is
crazy
and then i got manic because of it i
think there's
the clear reason why i feel nervous
i don't want to disrespect him or his
family or anything they're saying i'll
defer but
you know from the outside if a
journalist starts acting crazy and
freaking out because they found a crazy
story i mean to me that makes sense
especially with who they're dealing with
it is fair to say though i mean
people get paranoid and go crazy i
thought you said you were going to shut
conspiracy theories down
during this episode i did what do you
mean no no yeah
yeah i mean it seems like this is uh
exactly what that is
i didn't say anyone killed him i'm
saying that like the reason
they may have perceived him as being
manic was because he was genuinely
terrified of some you know big story he
uncovered yeah and it could have been a
tragic accident it's
it's just that simple that's a good
point it's it's the challenge of
being on the outside of these stories
and the problem with jumping the gun
is again it makes it harder to actually
uncover what happened
but then of course sometimes the truth
never comes out so what do you do
therein lies the the the bigger
challenge did we just sit back and say
i guess it was an accident you know if
this guy
if it was anybody else who did this we
wouldn't think twice we'd be like a guy
on an accent you know
good point but it was a journalist
working on a story and because of our
our assumptions
and because some people want to believe
right because of movies
right you know people are going to be
like it's a conspiracy that's
interesting but maybe it's nothing i
don't know man
hopefully um maxwell gets to testify yep
and uh that's it hopefully
she gets to testify and we'll uncover
what's really going on indeed
man i'll tell you what there's a lot of
things that i i'm going to avoid saying
just be
very very careful but the more time goes
on
the more it seems that our collective
narrative
is falling apart completely like
we used to all as a country believe
specific things that were like
held to be true yeah now it seems like
nothing makes sense anymore
like we mentioned you know uh joe biden
defunding the police
and you end up with like 70 stories and
one says he did say
he didn't say he did say he didn't say
it he means it but he means something
else
70 stories and 68 of them said
that he didn't say it and then the last
two you find it's like
actually he did here's the video but you
have to understand the context
but it's not he didn't exactly say it
that way
and then you have to look at the next
the next site that says this is actually
the definition
so going by that that's that's what he's
actually meaning so it's
and that's it's interesting but what
happens if you find you know
so town hall says yes joe biden wants to
defund the police
what happens then when you read that and
then someone you know reads the other
one
right now you both have a totally
fractured view of reality well
and there's this video going around
right now with all these celebrities
on facebook that i saw today that said
look if you
if you think that you know fake news
exists
you have to do some digging check
another news source and then check a
different news source that's also
trusted
because then you'll kind of get to see
what the real truth is and i'm just
scratching my head like oh my gosh like
that's
so you that's exactly what they want you
to do like oh go to this
this place in this place see they
cooperate so but you do
it makes sense yeah i know but you you
don't go to
just different news i'm going to do
quotes you gotta you gotta go through
like because that isn't
those aren't that's not that's not how
it works you gotta watch that you gotta
read the source that they use
go to what they're talking about the
actual speech the actual
video of the things that are actually
happening and that's what i've been
doing and i'm seeing like well see it's
not
that you know it's wrong so i actually i
actually posted your video
or no our video that we we talk about it
i think from last week or something yeah
was that the calendar
kennedy or no trump no it was the trump
trump talking about how biden
wants to defund the police and it's like
he actually absolutely does
from from the context of what he was
saying in that interview that's exactly
what he's saying
so it's like how can you deny that look
at
look at the actual speech of what he was
talking about and then go to
all the news sort the trusted news
sources that they would say go check
and it's all it's all whatever narrative
they're pushing which is there was go
biden basically
there was a post from eric weinstein uh
weinstein earlier
and he asked he said he's noticed a lot
of people who are like liberal
saying they're going to vote for trump
for one of two reasons either his
cognitive decline
or because of the new experiment in
policing where they actually
don't in the pacific northwest oh yeah
and a bunch of people responded saying
they're hearing similar things
i was talking to a friend of mine who i
met at a black lives matter protest
a young woman holding a big sign black
lives matter who now posts like
maga memes really yeah and so i dm her
and i'm like
so you're voting for trump and she
responded definitely and then i put
i met you in a black lives matter rally
exclamation point and she was like right
and then i was like i get it i dig it
and then i i post about it in a video
when i when i tweeted what weinstein
said about these liberals not leftists
liberals who are now jumping ship and
going to trump like
in droves i hear the same thing from all
these lefty journalists
this one journalist was like hipster
coffee shop am i right
and that's a meme that's basically
saying i went to a hipster coffee shop
and i overheard them say this
but i really am hearing this yeah and i
brought up you too
and i'm like if you know people like
adam who are not was not super political
is now like reading all the stuff and
being like yo i'm gonna vote for trump
yeah
then is that not enough i'm not saying
it's it's definitive data that trump is
winning i'm saying it's happening though
true like dude i'm not kidding this is
somebody i met literally at a black
at like the big ferguson protests right
who's now totally for trump i mean i
don't know why you don't go ahead
you know why the trafficking issue yeah
i mean and it makes sense i mean looking
into it i just read what he said
he he's pushing he put 400 million
dollars to to
stop it you know it's like yeah like
that's awesome
and i i'm actually finding more about
that now and i wish i
i had it for the episode that i did last
week you know so it's like
man like that's a huge a huge thing
bravo president bravo i i did a um
i think a fair conspiratorial tweet
earlier
i say fair in that it's not like
considered to be crazy
yeah i said what if the reason that
you know i'll give you the gist of it
what if the reason that everything is so
crazy
in our country right now is because
we're basically the only nation that can
stop
china's concentration camps oh i've read
that i saw that tweet
and there are billionaires in this
country who have serious financial
interests in china that are worried
so they use their money to influence
politics in this country to make sure we
don't mess with their financial
interests
i saw that tweet and i have to agree
with you man well you know why i tweeted
it
i i'm assuming you're gonna tell me
because of mark cuban oh yeah that
because ted cruz and mark cuban were
tweeting at each other
and ted cruz asked mark cuban if he
could tweet free hong kong
and mark cuban was like uh how you know
i can tweet black lives matter and i can
criticize this country
if you he's like i'll definitely
criticize china as it pertains to
american citizens but i never get
involved in domestic politics
and i saw that and i was like what yeah
there's a
genocide going on what do you mean you
don't get involved
i got three letters for you just being
blind
exactly cuban owns what is it the
mavericks yeah i think some maverick
action there
yeah maybe and i started thinking about
his interests
and why he won't say and the genocide
because he's going to lose money they
would seize his assets in two seconds
that's true
that's my opinion i'm not saying that's
really true but i do think it's it's
um vomitous
to uh to invoke um like i throw up on my
mouth a little bit
when he says i don't get involved in the
domestic politics of other countries
and realize that loading a bunch of
people into a concentration camp and
harvesting their organs was just a
domestic policy policy issue you
you didn't want to get involved in did
you see that uh i think it was a uk
um reporter talking to the
whoever the chinese guy they sent yeah
you saw that and he was just like we we
don't have concentration camps
and he's like here's a video i was like
okay well what do you call them then
that's all i was thinking you know it's
like that's what they do yeah yeah
exactly
twitter twitter did that when when they
were like we don't
shadowban what we do is we make it so
that when you post things no one can see
it but they don't realize it
and we're like but that's literally [ __ ]
that's the game they play
we don't call it shadow batting though
we don't do that here yeah so this bbc
clip was nuts they show the clip of the
people being loaded into trains and all
that stuff shaved heads
and he goes oh it's a normal prisoner
transfer like you do in the in the
united states
oh no no he didn't he he was like how do
you know that that's real how do you
know
he said prisoner transfers wow he said
we have prison missed that part
yeah he said just like in many countries
we do prison transfers
but he did say he's like how where did
you even get this footage from i've not
seen it i can't verify it right
and then he started saying like the
uyghur population is going up and all
the stuff
yeah and then he and then those
statistics too he goes all the way back
to like the 60s or something yeah
yeah but from from the 60s to now it's
double
it's double and he's like i asked you
about just the past
two years and he went back like 40 years
it's like
what well i'll tell you what man the
good news is noise
uh i believe he won he did he goes right
he got enough he got enough signatures
to
um go before parliament and uh well
to trigger the parliamentary right
exactly so hopefully
hopefully it works i mean yeah i'm
really really happy for him for those
that aren't familiar magic noise
is this very prominent speaker in in
london
on uh it's the lbc i guess it's a radio
network okay but he's like an
intellectual dark web guy so i'm sure
many of you are familiar with him he was
on a hunger strike
to try and get attention for a petition
to raise a hundred to get a hundred
thousand signatures to
so that parliament would address the the
ongoing
genocide in in china with the weaker
muslims and he succeeded
so i'm i'm happy about it and i've been
thinking you know i was thinking about
it earlier today after i saw this ted
cruz thing
and i was thinking about i was talking
to some of my friends and i can't i
can't believe how many times i've been
asking somebody about it and they go
wait
is that really happening right and i was
like are you for real
like yes wow dude i didn't know that
people didn't know this thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode